[Musik] vor genau zwei Jahren habe ich
den San Sebastian Cheesecake gebacken
und damit die Cheesecake Welt auf den Kopf
gestellt ich bin unendlich dankbar dass so
viele Menschen jedes Wochenende mein San
Sebastian Cheesecake nachbacken für mich
ist das eines der leckersten Cheesecakes der
Welt gleichzeitig ist die Zubereitung auch
die einfachste der Welt ihr müsst lediglich die
Zutaten die ich euch in die Kommentare schreibe
zusammenrühren wichtig ist dass man wirklich
nur so lange wie notwendig wird und nicht zu
lange wir wollen keine Luft reinschlagen sondern
die Masse super schön cremig haben auch wichtig
ist dass man beim Vanille nicht spart falls ihr
kein Vanilleextrakt habt dann nehmt gerne eine
richtige Vanilleschote eine auslaufsichere
Springform schützt einfach vor Frustration
und dass euch das ganze ausläuft und noch viel
wichtiger ist eure Backzeit jeder Backofen backt
anders und es kommt wirklich auf jede Minute
an genauso muss ein Zahn Sebastian Cheesecake
aussehen und am besten schmeckt er mir mit
ein bisschen voll die Schokolade [Musik]